habituellement ce qu évident mais ce
matin pas moins de dix bateaux amarrés
les propriétaires sont à quelques mètres
des marins pêcheurs de plus en plus
réticents à l'idée de partir au large
non seulement 7 ans et plus je fais des
films comme des quasi doit acheter des
petits sachets de classe c soit +12 5 eu
le droit joint à glacer la faute à cette
machine à glace en panne depuis quatre
mois la ctm a effectué des premières
réparations mais leur est estimé à 1200
euros tarde à venir et les pêcheurs
s'impatiente
sur les étals du marché ont fait avec le
système d la glace est dur on est
obligés d'aller de l'avant sans la
station chose qui n'est pas normal que
nous avons deux appareils à glace ont
fait avec la qualité de la glace ça
convient non elles font trop vite cette
classe là une alternative coûteuse avec
en moyenne un budget classe x 4 selon
les marins pêcheurs
une difficulté qui vient s'ajouter à
d'autres si vous voyez auto non
seulement il ya pas que la machine à gaz
sur le point qui n'est plus un pouce une
porcherie y aller tous les affrontements
et les abris de pêche pour les pêcheurs
sont obligés de se débrouiller eux mêmes
de mettre des feuilles de tôle pour
éviter que l'on rentre dedans et puis
aujourd'hui et là on constate que la
machine à glace ah ben ça fait quatre
mois qu'elle est en panne dommage on
n'avait pas besoin on a déjà un monument
aux morts sur la place de ce critère n'a
pas besoin de 2e ligue
une partie des pêcheurs de trinité a
décidé de se cotiser pour financer la
réparation mais la ctm propriétaire de
la machine à glace pourrait bien s'y
opposer d'autant plus que l'attribution
du marché pour la réparation de
l'ensemble des machines de l'île est en
cours et que le cadre de trinité et du
vauclin devraient être traitées en
priorité